Now, once you've setup the layout of the
app, it's time to take a moment to talk
about what's actually
happening in the final app.
If you remember,
we have the map on the screen,
which is somehow modified by
pressing the buttons at the top.
Now, thus far, we've learned
how to make a map fragment and
change that through user activity.
But we haven't learned how to create
a Google Map object, which is the thing
that within code will be able to change
the contents of the map fragment.
So to do this there's
a few things that we need.
First of all, we'll need to
implement the onMapReadyCallback.
Now we'll do that by modifying the class
declaration for our main activity to
have this, so here I have my onMapReady
which is just setting mapReady,
a boolean ,to true, and then this
local variable called m_map to map.
And you notice here it passes back
a Google Map, so my m_map, of course,
is a local instance of a Google Map.
And you can see I've defined it
at the top of my activity here.
And of course the activity itself has
to implement the onMapReady callback.
So, within our onMapReady,
I'm just saying the mapReady is true.
I'm loading my local instance of a map
with the one that was sent back to me.
I create a new lat-long, which I'm
calling New York, with the latitude and
longitude coordinates
we used earlier on.
Then I'm setting the camera position
using a camera position builder.
I'm targeting at New York, and
I'm setting the zoom to 14,
so it'll be a little bit further
out than the one we saw earlier.
And then on m map itself,
now the map object,
I can call the move camera on that to
set its position to be this target.
As you can see,
it's pretty straight forward.
And you can do other things like angling
and zooming to different levels and
different types of views that you want
on the camera position itself, but
here I've created a very
basic camera position.
So that's all that you really need
to do to get your map set up for
working within an application and
having a handle on a map object
that you can then program.
And I'll show you in the next
step how we then program that
to allow to have satellite or
height reviews.